ach ja der winter jedes jahr dritter uns
wieder aufs neue in den arsch und
schickt den sommer weg wiesen türstehern
zu betrunkenen gast ich gehe ja zu den
leuten die auf beide jahreszeiten stehen
ja klar da sag mal ist schon cool aber
der winter kann halt auch echt knorke
sein sorry ich habe ein anderes wort für
cool gesucht und mir ist nur knorke
eingefallen und jetzt merke ich dass
knocke gar nicht so cool so verrückt wie
ich bin
ich bin so verrückt ich lese shades of
grey und feuchtgebiete und shakes gleich
zwei oder drei ich weiß es nicht die
börse nicht nummeriert werde ich euch
jetzt die vorteile des winters da liege
ich
hasse wenn da
auch immer diese mitbewohner die
einbringen stimmen im winter kann man
coole mützen tragen und keiner fragt
irgendwie blöd von der seite wird mal
ehrlich zu wärmende mütze obwohl man in
einem geschlossenen raum ist und es warm
ist und die mütze eigentlich nicht
vonnöten ist so weil du aber im sommer
eine mütze trägt kriegst du halt den
arsch tritt arschtritt und genauso ist
es mit sonnenbrillen ich mein im winter
ist es doch genauso hell wie im sommer
wenn nicht sogar manchmal heller wegen
dem ganzen schnee und dann kommt keiner
auf die idee meine sonnenbrille
anzuziehen und wenn ich dann da immer
super cool mit meiner song brille
herumlaufen und mir denke immer die
sonne kam ich nicht blenden dann kriege
ich immer so blöd blicke so ist doch
kein sommer warum trägst du eine
sonnenbrille mach's gut logik der winter
ist kuschelig ob du mit deinem freund
oder deiner freundin auf der couch
stundenlang serien schaust weil man das
ja im sommer nicht machen kann ich mein
bett kuschelt im sommer wirklich so
körper an körper macht keiner ist viel
zu warm dafür ein schlitz die ganze zeit
das ist scheiße wenn du auch nicht ich
weiß es jeder hat schon mal verschwitzt
niemandem gelegen und dachte sich
und wenn man in keiner beziehung ist
kann man halt trotzdem stundenlang auf
der couch liegen und keiner kommt mit
diesem blöden spruch warum werften
jahren für zeitarbeiter auf der couch
bis zur etwa ein
wahrer
denn was soll man sonst im winter tun
der süßkram ob man auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt gebrannte mandeln ein
liebes apfel oder eine schoko banane ist
oder sich bei aldi um die ecke schnell
einpacken league auftakt ist der winter
bringt die besten süßigkeiten mit sich
und jetzt kommt das beste daran man
zeigt im winter keine haut also nicht so
viel das heißt es essen essen essen
essen wo du du kannst ist ist den ganzen
winter lang damit du dich dann im
frühling wieder recht fühlst aber
darüber denken wenn ich im november nach
das sind erst gedanken für den märz wenn
der schmerz kommt mit der ersten hose
die kurz ist
und da wir gerade von weihnachtsmarkt
sprechen im winter ist weihnachten und
da brauche ich glaube ich nicht viel zu
sagen oder und keiner kann mir erzählen
dass dadurch die einkaufstasche
pauschalen durch die einkaufshäuser geht
und dessen speicher schmuck nicht
wunderschön findet weil er ich
wunderschön ja jedes jahr wieder sieht
zwar jedes jahr gleich aus aber es jedes
jahr wieder rechnen und einmal im jahr
denkt nicht jeder nur an sich selbst
sondern auch an seine liebsten und wir
setzen uns an einen tisch und schaffen
es den ganzen abend lang an einem tisch
zu bleiben und zu essen und zu trinken
und uns zu freuen dass man sich hat und
das ist doch der grundgedanke von
weihnachten last but not least der
winter hat silvester und semester ist
cool
für jedermann außer für depressive die
sich an silvester das leben nehmen
darüber spricht sich natürlich möchte
ich auch fair bleiben und die nachteile
erwähnen eine viel zu warme bahn kalte
füße zu kurze tage obdachlose frieren
man wird fett viel zu warme
einkaufsläden rollkragenpullover kälte
nässe gefrorene nässe geschmolzene
gefrorene nässe und das christmas album
von justin bieber ich wollte euch sagen
es ist schluss für heute da unten könnt
ihr mich
abonnieren links und rechts gibt es noch
zwei weitere videos
und jetzt ist mit dem video
schluss und das ist das schlimmste lied
aller zeiten darum mache ich
unterhaltung und keine musik
tschüss